happy Thanksgiving ladies and gentlemen
it's a time of year we all gather round
and we say thanks for the things we're
thankful for
yeah I'm thankful for friends I'm
thankful for you Carmichael I have to
put an asterisk there friends and
Carmichael two different things so I
always ask the question what would you
like to do if money were no object what
would how would you really enjoy
spending your life I am thankful for my
Austin family awesome group of friends
awesome group of dudes who are also my
friends that I get to work with every
day I'm thinking for you guys being able
to let me do this awesome job
Happy Thanksgiving cereal is that really
art well it's so amazing as a result of
our kind of educational system crowds of
students say well we'd like to be
painters we'd like to be poets we'd like
to be writers but as everybody knows you
can't earn any money that way you know
what I'm thankful for fan art free video
ideas that people email us if you get to
the point where are you making videos
and people email you their ideas and
they're like hey you know I was just
thinking about this the other day here's
my idea that is a very special place to
be I'll always hold those in my heart
even if I don't respond no seriously
though thank you
when we finally got down to something
which the individual says he really
wants to do I will say to him you do
that and forget the money because if you
say that getting the money is the most
important thing you will spend your life
completely wasting your time you'll be
doing things you don't like doing in
order to go on living that is to go on
doing things you don't like doing which
is stupid I am thankful has anyone think
to the audience yet I assume everyone's
going to be making them because that's
why we're here way too many right now
I'm saying why we're here as a company
because we would have floundered years
ago if there weren't anyone here to
watch our stuff thank you for being
patient with us as we stumble through
how to figure out how to do any of this
it's really cool it's a thank you for
saying hi to me if you ever see me in
person that's really cool I'm thankful
for the community that you all have
fostered on both reddit in the comments
on YouTube I'm thankful that you have
provided me with a sort of career that I
never would have ever anticipated better
to have a short life that is full of
what you like doing than a long life
spent in a miserable way and after all
if you do really like what you're doing
it doesn't matter what it is you can
eventually turn it you will eventually
become a master of it the only way to
become a master is something to be
really with it and then you'll be able
to get a good fee for whatever it is and
anything you could be interested in you
will find others but it's absolutely
stupid
spend your time doing things you don't
like in order to go on spending things
you don't like and doing things you
don't like and to teach your children to
follow in the same track well I don't
know I had a special year oh how do I
put it well I mean I'm just generally
thankful that Sarah myself moved into
our first home together this year and
also I having a baby boy which is pretty
crazy to say but what I'm thankful for
about it is that so far everything's
gone so well and I know that's not the
case for for everyone sometimes you know
people have problems in life and the
problems suck when you have them I've
had a very smooth the air especially a
smooth year coinciding with huge life
events happening is something definitely
to be thankful for that's like this
super serious answer and it's all about
me I guess so but that's what I'm think
I've that's what I'm thankful I'm
thankful for having such a huge year
also having a very smooth year because
when people have huge life changes like
the ones I'm in encountering right now
just just having everything be nice and
smooth like it means everything right
now the moment you have a situation
where you are really in control of
things that is to say in which the
future is almost completely predictable
a completely predictable future is
already the past you've had it
that's not what you want you want a
surprise you don't know what that's
gonna be because obviously it wouldn't
be a surprise if you did I'm thankful
for all of you watching her videos
enjoying these adventures we go on
learning with us growing with us and
letting us entertain you on this channel
I'm also super thankful for this
wonderful team we have around us if you
guys have been around since the
beginning of corridor digital you
remember that's just a couple of us
doing these things weird kooky videos
online but now it's blown up into a
whole group of friends and colleagues
and co-workers and the artists who are
working together to do some really cool
stuff and that's with all of your
support so I'm thankful for all these
guys including this guy behind the
camera and they glow for you for
watching where do you think before
Carmichael
[Music]